So you believe that the dream could
contain more information then was yet
articulated.
You think artists do the same thing?
You know,
like people go to museums and they look
at paintings,
renaissance paintings or modern
paintings and they don't exactly know
why they're there.
Now I was in this room and in New York,
I don't remember which museum,
but it was a room full of renaissance
art,
you know,
great painters,
the greatest painters and thought maybe
that room was worth $1 billion or
something outrageous because there was
like 20 paintings in there,
you know,
so priceless.
And the first thing is,
well,
why are those paintings worth so much
and why is there a museum in the biggest
city in the world devoted to them?
And why do people from all over the
world come and look at them?
What the hell are those people doing?
One of them was of the assumption of
Mary,
you know,
beautifully painted,
absolutely glowing work of art.
There's like 20 people standing in front
of it looking at it and think,
what are those people up to?
You know,
they don't know.
Why did they make a pilgrimage to New
York to come and look at that painting?
It's not like they know.
Why is it worse so much?
I mean,
I know there's a status element to it
too,
but that begs the question,
why did those items become such high
status items?
What is it about them that's so
absolutely remarkable?
Well,
we're strange creatures.